Anisha Islam breaks down as she
describes the moment she heard how her
father Ismail Hussein was abducted by
armed police in the maple area of Dhaka
four years on there's no trace of the
businessman
I have a feeling my father is still
alive and would like to know where he's
now if you've killed him then please let
us know where he's buried then no one
will have to worry that he's still
missing at least then I can have a
funeral for him
local and international human rights
organizations say more than 600
bangladeshis have been forcibly
disappeared since 2009. some returned
home but refused to talk for fear of
reprisal many others were found dead in
remote locations jumu actor's brother
went missing in 2015. police later said
that the student and the opposition
political activist had died in custody
they detained me along with my parents
and my brother who was the main target
and ultimately became a victim of
custodial torture and death I was kept
in jail after he died for another six
months
kalpana and Michael chuckman were
protesting voices against oppression and
harassment of the indigenous people in
the chattergram hill tracks region
Witnesses say both where victims of
forced disappearances by State security
forces
we have one demand that everyone along
with Michael and kalpana chakma who are
victims of enforced disappearances be
immediately released
the number of unforced disappearances
and extrajudicial killings has fallen
significantly since 2021 that was when
the U.S government imposed sanctions on
commanders of the rapid action Battalion
that's the country's Elite
anti-terrorism police unit for rights
abuse and the role in enforced
disappearances
in recent months family members are the
victims of enforced disappearance have
been subjected to intimidation and
harassment by members of the law
enforcement and intelligence agencies
sanjid Islam's brother was seized by
Security Forces 10 years ago the
opposition party leader is still missing
all the family members want is for those
who are victims of enforced
disappearances and subject to torture
and secret detention cells to return
home every day we still dream of uniting
with them
the Bangladesh government has dismissed
the allegation as false and fabricated
and government ministers have repeatedly
failed to respond to concerns raised by
the UN the U.S and other foreign
governments tanvi Chaudhary Al Jazeera
Dhaka
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera